this doggy diva nearly ruined the hunt
for the perfect shot but what 80s movie
inspired the pup's inclusion in prey
since its premiere on hulu the action
horror film prey has garnered massive
amounts of success not only did price
set a jaw-dropping hulu viewership
record upon its release but the movie
also has a 92 critic score on rotten
tomatoes as of the making of this video
the character-driven story centers
around a young comanche woman named naru
who is intent on completing her first
big hunt when the male hunters in her
community fall victim to the alien
menace known as the predator it is up to
naru to save her friends and family but
when it comes to the best main
characters in prey special mention must
be given to naru's dog sorry
there you are
a faithful canine companion sari is
naru's constant ally who helps her
through all her trials alien and
otherwise as it turns out director dan
trachtenberg looked to another classic
action film series for inspiration for
naaru's furry friend just as prey calls
back to the original predator it also
draws influence from another fan
favorite film of the 80s but instead of
aliens it is a dystopian tale set in
australia while being interviewed ahead
of the film's release director dan
trachtenberg revealed that sorry was
inspired by mad max 2 aka the road
warrior the film depicts max rockatansky
as he tries to survive in a
post-apocalyptic wasteland max is the
epitome of a loner type but is not
without his trusty canine companion this
appealed to the director of prey who
wanted to include that dynamic in his
own film he told decerto road warrior
was a big inspiration for having a
badass and their dog i love having there
be this buddy relationship with this
creature with another animal amidst a
predator film the director also recalled
showing friends and family cuts of the
film before it was finished and everyone
was asking for more of sorry he told
fresh fiction i was like you don't
understand we are using every usable
frame of this dog it turns out there
were a lot of unusable frames of the pup
for good reason sorry is played by a
civilian dog named coco who has zero
film experience nauru actress amber mid
thunder told deserto she was a little
bit of a hot mess but in a sweet way she
was not a movie dog she was literally
adopted to be in this movie and she just
happened to be very high energy dan
trachtenberg agreed noting that coco was
super rambunctious very energetic always
a nail-biting moment for us on set is
koko gonna like make her mark and do
what she needs to do it was sometimes a
journey to get there but eventually she
always did it was very exciting lots of
cheers would happen when we finally got
a great take with coco trachtenberg also
revealed that sari was never going to be
in the movie as much as she was but they
decided to include her more and more as
filming went on even though she didn't
always nail her takes it sounds like the
result was more than worth the effort
[Music]